Like many international organizations, the
International Criminal Court is great in theory,
but a failure in practice. It was formally
founded in 2002 with the admirable goal of
ending war crimes, crimes against humanity,
aggression, and genocide. But it has not
accomplished its mission. In theory, the ICC an
independent legal institution above politics.
In practice, its political agenda devotes
unequal attention to America, Israel, and African
nations. In theory, the ICC only steps in where
national courts aren't fit to investigate crimes.
In practice, the ICC targets US soldiers
who've already been tried in American courts,
yet it ignores the grave human rights violations
committed by Venezuela, China, and Russia. In less
than 20 years, more than 2 billion dollars have
been spent with only nine successful convictions,
all against African nations. The ICC's silence
is a betrayal to millions living under tyranny.
Do you think the ICC needs
reform? Let us know in our poll.
Also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.